[Music]
well today joe biden demanded demanded
passage of something called hr1 it's the
very first piece of legislation democrat
sponsored it's the
for the people act that ought to make
you nervous that law would allow
democratic operatives to go door to door
collecting mail-in ballots it would
legalize voter fraud
democrats have said for months that if
you oppose this then you're a racist you
support
jim crow making it harder for younger
poorer non-white and typically
democratic voters
to have to access the ballot shame
shame shame this is why when the states
start to enact these kinds of voter
suppression laws what i call
feel your vote laws is to try to deny
people of color
young people poor people the right to
vote people with disabilities
the right to vote like you can't go to
the polls like people have for 250 years
are you joking
these people will literally say anything
to increase their own power
even the weak sisters in the senate
didn't buy it on the republican side
it's got no chance of passing
republicans blocked it today using the
filibuster so now
in the complex dance that is the
legislative process democrats are
suddenly open to a compromise
offered by joe manchin of west virginia
and that compromise would include
voter id laws that virtually every
person in america including majorities
of black people for whatever it's worth
support you need one to cash a check why
not to vote
and yet it was just a few weeks ago that
stacy abrams the oracle of georgia was
telling us
that's racism now she's telling us oh
it's a good idea
no one has ever objected to having to
prove who you are
to vote it's been part of our nation's
history since the inception of voting
voters without a driver's license or
state id must surrender their personal
information
and risk identity theft just to receive
an absentee ballot and then there are
the 200 000
georgia voters who don't have either id
and the punitive free id that is not
free when you factor in the cost of
transportation
and the cost of underlying document
it just makes your head spin brit hume
is fox news's senior
political analyst by virtue of his
wisdom not age
he joins us tonight brit i just need a
sane person to bounce us off of one
sentence i feel like i'm going crazy
i've sat on the set for the last five
years
in fact i think been called a racist for
saying that people ought to
show id before they vote is that you'd
run a car stay in a hotel or fly a plane
now they're telling us they were always
for that have i gone insane did i have a
stroke what
what is this well the clip you just
showed from stacey abrams who's one of
those saying that
you know nobody no one was ever really
opposed to this that proves that people
were and she was one of them
um the problem they're having now of
course tucker is that voter id
is wildly popular i mean something on
the order of 80
according to one current poll and that
poll reflects earlier polling on this
issue going back a number of years
people think voter id is a good idea and
the bill
h.r one or s1 if you're considering in
the senate
would would loosen voter id provisions
in
all across the country which a number of
states already have
so um already have voter id requirements
in fact it would say that well if you
didn't have a voter id you could
you could swear out a statement saying
you are who you say you are which
seems to me wouldn't be terribly
effective but but that's what the bill
was saying and that's one of the reasons
why i was opposed and one of the reasons
why
republicans felt quite safe in opposing
it
if you wanted to restore the public's
faith in clean elections indeed if you
wanted to have clean elections why
wouldn't you have the elections we've
had for hundreds of years where you go
to the polling place and vote on a paper
ballot there's a record of how you voted
there are neutral observers there to
make sure that no one cheats
why wouldn't we do that well
one reason why we wouldn't do that is
that i think it is believed by
democrats you heard chuck schumer
categorizing some of them
uh some of their voters that that the
easier you make it for people to vote
the more of their voters will turn out
and
and and and and vote and elect them
so they want to make it you know very
easy and they refer to all these bills
that
are being enacted around the country in
various states
as restricted well every voter
law every voting provision law is
restricted to some extent for example
we don't allow people to vote by phone
or to vote over the internet
well why do we do that we do that to
protect against the kind of fraud
that would arise when you make voting so
easy that anybody can do it and it
and it becomes you know not simply uh
easy to vote but hard to cheat it
becomes easy to vote and easy to cheat
and that's of course the tension there
between those two things
yeah of people vote telepathically we
also want to point out just in the
interest of our comprehensive news
coverage here
in the hour that it is in fact your
birthday bret hume
and we want to wish you the very
happiest possible birthday a man can
have do you have any words of wisdom
for our viewers well well i yes i would
have
this word of wisdom for our viewers um
if you get to be my age and i'm not
going to say what it is
take good care of yourself because
you'll have aches and pains
and i have them you also will find as
joe biden has and i have to some extent
that your memory and what it used to be
nor is the color of your hair
as it was reflected in that photo you
just put up there so thank you for those
good wishes tucker thank you very much
man you're doing better than anyone else
i know at your age
well thanks bret hume the great brit
hume thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else